[Música]
los mejores cineastas del mundo tienen
una pero la palma de oro creada por
primera vez por news y enlazó es
rediseñada cada año por nuevos artistas
generalmente la palma se presenta sobre
un cristal de roca este año hemos
utilizado un cuarzo rosa la idea de la
palma es en referencia a las palmeras de
la riviera de canela
desde san felipe
la palma simboliza con sus árboles
siempre verdes pero la preciosa joya es
fabricada a cientos de kilómetros de
distancia en ginebra suiza con 118
gramos de oro amarillo que se funden a
más de 1000 grados para producir el
molde una primera palma se hace con algo
no tan precioso
o sea está hecha de cera es una técnica
muy práctica y precisa que remonta el
antiguo egipto desde su visión la palma
de cera se recubre con eso cuando el
molde se calienta la cera se derrite y
se sustituye por el oro 15 horas más
tarde cuando el oro está sólido se quita
el yeso con agua y ácido
luego se lleva a una docena de joyeros
que lo curen durante horas este año la
palma también ha sido cubierta con 100
diamantes
la concentración es la clave no podemos
resbalar y tenemos que asegurarnos que
cada diamante se inserte en el lugar
correcto
esta es la palma de oro número 75 es
casi única será entregada a un solo
artista pero los joyeros hicieron una
copia extra por si acaso
[Música]